the first thing i want to ask you is
what is the origin of marriage like are
you familiar with that story
yeah i'm sort of no it was always
political right like historically these
things were for political unions right
back in the
you know english common law these were
really meant to tie estates together
to make sure that you know in
agricultural society
that you know the wife was taken care of
she wasn't left uh
you know on the streets without some
sort of you know compensation because
she wasn't working she wasn't able to
um obtain an income and you know
concepts like common law
emerged because and if you see the
states where they still exist or where
they're still on the books
a lot of them were frontier states so
they were out in the middle of nowhere
where there's no judge there's no um
you know court system or government and
people would just live together on a
farm
and you know never solidify it so they
said okay we need some process because
the woman needs to be able
to take this when her husband dies of
dysentery
on the oregon trail you know you're
going to need somebody to
take that over yeah there's a there's a
really good book by this author her
name's stephanie cootes
and she wrote a book called marriage
history
and she basically collected court
records personal diaries like every
every person every every piece of data
that she could throughout history as far
back as
was available and it really boils down
to this the whole point of marriage has
never been about love it's always been
about the acquisition of in-laws
i mean that's a huge benefit if you
think about it especially back in the
day when you're thinking about
you know business linking lands making
connections
that was really how things were done
traditionally but there was no state
interference if you wanted to untie the
knot and get rid of your wife you just
send her off and you'd probably keep the
kids
and everything she brought to the table
right and there usually had to be a good
reason to annular marriage especially if
you're in a catholic country where it
wasn't really supported unless it was
like a crazy reason
um so i mean you needed some fault
now we're in a no fault situation even
my
um mother when i asked her um oh then i
see the no followers
no phone right there
no fault divorce and maybe the history
and how it changed over time cheers and
thanks for the content thank you yeah i
mean
obviously that changed in the benefit of
the or during the sexual revolution
because you know before you had to have
some sort of reason so infidelity would
have been a reason and even like i said
when i talked to my mother
she said well you know if you if your
wife cheats then that's reason for
divorce
i said mom we don't need that anymore
you may be thinking way back but that
doesn't exist
you can get divorced because you feel
like it it's no fault
so um you know and there are a couple
states that have this weird thing called
covenant marriage which which you know
limits the reasons to kind of
pre-sexual revolution where there has to
be infidelity
or some other major issue with domestic
violence this is
an at-fault divorce because there was a
guy that i had on last
week that that basically had a private
investigator fall around his wife
uh collected data on who who she was
banging basically
yeah took a lot of evidence and yeah
there's a lot of drugs that were
involved as well too but
okay long story short because of the
fault process that he used he ended up
getting full custody she pays him money
um and like it it was just a total win
for him like the whole thing
but you guys that's crazy the last
episode it's number 85
you'd have to watch that you know figure
out the situation and you got to know
that that situation may not apply where
you live and may not apply to your
situation
so even if you hire that private
investigator even if you catch her in
the act and you've got the bag of
cocaine
you may not still be able to do anything
in terms of alimony
or that maybe it'll apply to child
support payments obviously if there's
drug involved
or drug related activities that's going
to impact any
custody but that's a separate issue
you